to present the next award are two
English artists whom I am do very much I
have a special admiration for him since
he did such a brilliant job playing me
and Alfie
he was later nominated for sleuth with
him is the gifted and alluring lady who
lured an Oscar to London for her
performance in the prime of Miss Jean
Brodie won't they ever forgive us for
the Boston Tea Party here is Mary Smith
and Michael Caine
Bob the first time I ever saw you was
when you appeared at the Prince of Wales
Theatre in London I was six
that's interesting how about you me I
was sitting in his lab well I don't mind
these little barbs I'm happy to be just
a part of this great industry I'm
delighted that artists of your caliber
pay any attention to me at all
truly I am the nominees for the
outstanding performance by an actor in a
supporting role our mikhail baryshnikov
in the turning point Peter Firth in
hecklers Alec Guinness in Star Wars
Jason Robards in julia maximilian schell
in Julia and I have the envelope and the
winner is
Jason roba
wishing very well in many
congratulations we've just got to get
off that so he's not looking sure the
time
I think he's playing bridge with Marlon
Brando and George Scott